hi I'm Paige we're gonna be talking
about fighting with my family today I'm
super excited it comes out February 14th
in LA and New York and everywhere else
around America on the 22nd and March 1st
in the UK I'm very excited but here
today on BuzzFeed we are we talking
about my first but keep your head up the
girl because it's not like that
[Music]
first time meat in the rock it was at
WrestleMania 2014 I got someone come up
to your life hey DJ wants to speak to
you so I was like who's that felt like
an idiot because they were like Dwayne
Johnson I was like oh well duh right and
I was like what the hell am I gonna say
to this guy he's like you know one of my
heroes when I first saw him you're like
yep here is magical and person as you
are on TV then he ended up telling me
that he's gonna make a movie on my
family and I was already cry my eyes out
straight after that story he was like
I'm by the way you're gonna be debuting
and you're gonna win the Divas
Championship tomorrow and I'm like well
first time you realized you were famous
I don't even feel famous though I'm easy
a d-class Larry may be a little bit high
but not like not not be not this not
seriously okay
first body power or burn you'd make
invincible to injury a little bit too
late
I had my neck messed up twice so you
know if I could it would be to make my
neck invincible first thing you did for
yourself after winning the Divas
Championship I actually called everyone
I knew and cried afterwards yeah I just
ate a bunch and got drunk first injury
in the ring I got knocked down on my
second match but then the week off
though me and my mom were wrestling and
she broke my wrist and then I got mad at
her and kicked her in the face and
prokhanov boom right back at you [ __ ]
first wrestling outfit oh my gosh I
would
strangely wearing all white in my
present outfit with silver sequins on
that that was the weirdest ever first
time you realize you wanted to pursue
rest pursue wrestling pepper
professionally was a hard apparently for
me today I've always loved it I just I
was so scared of doing it then one day
my dad was like hey one of the girls
don't turn up for work today can you
jump in it like 13 years old and I was
like yeah yeah definitely I have no idea
what I'm doing
and I was knocked at my first match -
they always a wonderful knockout I loved
it
then I was like well me being a vet went
out the window okay first piece of
advice you'd give someone who wants to
wrestle in WWE
be patient
and I'll give you the same advice that
Dwayne gave to me you want to stay
humble and you want to stay hungry and
patient love a good first big wrestling
win when I first won Dixie winstram ship
against Emma boom first point you had
when you step in the Derby to read for
the first time nothing beats the feeling
of getting inside i debit every ring
when you finally get on the road like
that blows your mind so like when I did
my debut which you'll see in the movie
of fighting with my family I couldn't
even explain the feeling on this just
like this is what I've been watching
like you know my whole life this is
insane pleasure of mine this is where
the rock star comes busting steadily is
dead Bullock on are like all these
amazing athletes and now I'm sending a
head tear like this little tiny pale
girl from Norwich and Harry I made it
and I can go sit back to you in studio
[Music]